let's say that you have a hunch that
sugar is somehow causing heart disease
is somehow causing heart disease and so
you want to research this further you
want to see how what kind of statistical
studies can you perform to better
understand sugar intake in the
population generally and whether that
seems to be causing heart disease in
some way well the first thing that you
might want to do is just to try to get a
sense of sugar intake in the population
as a whole now clearly you don't know
you there's no way of measuring exactly
how much sugar every member let's say
you're talking about the United States
every member of that 300 million
population is consuming every day so
that we the way that we try to get a
sense of how much sugar is being
consumed is by conducting a sample study
so you take your population your 300
million people so you take your your
population right over here
population and you sample it you sample
your population and you not only do
sample it but you randomly sample it
obviously you don't want to just survey
people who are exiting a cupcake store
or people who are exiting a gym you want
to be a random a random sample of people
where where you're sampling them
shouldn't be shouldn't somehow affect
whether or not their answer or how much
sugar they might say that they are
consuming but they're going to tell you
how much sugar they consume let's say on
an average day maybe by filling out a
survey or through some other way and
through that you would take you take
this data and obviously the more samples
you have the better and we talked about
that in depth and other statistics
videos about how how you get a better
predictor of the actual true population
parameter the more samples that you
might take but you might do that to get
a gauge of how much sugar the average
American consumes in a given day so this
right over here where you are taking
random samples of the population to
essentially generate astute it a
statistic that is estimating a true
parameter which is the actual amount of
sugar America
are consuming each day we call this a
sample study sample sample study it's a
way once again of just estimating what
the actual amount of sugar people are
having each day but let's say you want
to go further this will just tell you
this will give you a sense of what is
likely the amount of sugar that people
are consuming each day but you really
want to see how that's related to heart
disease so you instead what you do is
you go survey people you go survey
people and you see you say well how much
sugar have you consumed over and once
again when you pick these people you
should be doing it randomly so let's say
that you go survey a random sample of 60
year-olds so once again you wouldn't
want to sample people who are in the
hospital you wouldn't want to sample
people who are at the ad or just at the
gym you would want to find a random
sample or sample them in places where it
shouldn't affect their answer which way
they're going to go but let's say you
were you surveyed 360 year-olds and you
asked them how much sugar have they
consumed over the last 30 years and you
also ask them their condition of their
heart and what you get is something like
this so on the horizontal axis you put
plot sugar consumption and then on the
vertical axis you plot you plot heart
disease risk or or their level of heart
disease heart disease risk let's say at
60 and you plot and you find a plot that
looks something like this so each of
these points so this is someone who
consumed let's say 200 grams of sugar
per day and they're now at high heart
disease risk now at age 60 but maybe
this is someone who is at low heart
disease risk at age 60 even though they
consumed a lot of sugar every day
and so we just keep plotting all of
these points and you say well you know
what it does look and obviously I'm not
going to do all 300 and you say well
actually it looks like there is a rough
correlation right over here that if you
try to plot a line there are definitely
some outliers here but
looks like it looks like there is a line
that you could fit and then so you might
say well it looks like sugar and heart
disease risk at age sixty that they are
correlated that they're related in this
way that they move together that if
someone consumed a lot of sugar over the
last thirty years they about they seem
to have worse heart situation and they
consumed a lot lower sugar they seem to
have a lower or a better heart situation
now and this is this often happens in
medical science when people see
something like this they often jump to
the gluten oh they're for sugar
consuming more sugar must drive up heart
disease risk and that's very dangerous
because just seeing this data doesn't
tell you that sugar is causing heart
disease risk it's it's it could go the
other way around it could be that people
who end up having a high heart disease
risk maybe they crave sugar but it's
actually there's some under under
there's some other under lysing cause
that's making it happen maybe they have
some other deficiency that's making them
cause sugar so it's not clear which way
the causality is happening is the sugar
consumption driving the unhealthy heart
or somehow the unhealthy heart driving
the sugar consumption or maybe there's
some other factor maybe there's fat
consumption is driving the heart disease
and maybe people have more fat also will
have more sugar or vice versa or who
knows so all this is telling you is that
there is a correlation so this right
over here you would call this an
observational study you've observed a
relationship but you can really can't
say what is causing what so let me write
this down this is an observational
observational study now you're probably
saying all right well then how could you
prove or get them or feel better about
the idea that sugar is actually a cause
that there's actually causality there
well to do that you would actually have
to run an experiment and experiment and
to do an experimental study here what
you would do is try to take two groups
of folks you would have your
experimental group so that's your
experimental group actually let me let
me make it a circle here so it's a pool
of people so let's say you have a
hundred people that are experimental
that's your experimental
cool and then you have your control you
have your control and what you would do
if you wanted to run this type of
experiment and as we'll see this type of
experiment probably wouldn't be run
because what some would consider it
unethical or actually I would consider
unethical as well but what you would do
is you would randomly let's say take 30
year-olds you would randomly take 30
year-olds and put them in one of these
two groups and once again when we say
randomly you don't want to put all the
healthy people in one group and all the
unhealthy people the other group
provides versa you want it to be random
you don't want to put all the people of
one type one demographic one economic
status in one group or the other you
want to be random so you randomly put
people into these two into these two
groups and then the experimental group
you would change one variable and the
variable you care about is sugar so what
you might say is okay all of the people
in this group right over here whatever
sugar that they would have consumed on
top of that they have to drink I don't
know they have to drink a cup of syrup
every night or they have to have or they
have to have a minimum sugar intake so
that you essentially force sugar into
this group that you're not forcing into
this group and then 30 years later so
one this is probably unethical to force
people to have something that is very
likely not good for their health and
then you would have to run it for a long
period of time you would wait 30 years
you would wait 30 years when they're 60
years old and you would see well what
was the heart condition of these folks
how many people maybe had heart attacks
well how many people at age 60 or who
are what's their health condition and
then is that statistically is it is it
unlikely that the difference would have
been pure do pure to would be do purely
to chance alone so for example if you
did this and let's say that now these
people had a slightly higher chance for
heart disease or heart attacks and these
folks after 30 years that still might
not be a convincing X it's still not it
would be a good experiment but it
wouldn't allow you to conclude that
sugar is causing it because that might
have happened through chance alone but
if for example after 30 years let's say
this group right over here has 10 times
the risk of a heart attack or 10 times
the you know whatever the risk factors
for heart disease and you would say and
you statistically say well but the odds
of that happening by chance alone that
the hundred people in this group right
over here having ten times the chance of
heart attack is this group right over
here that's unlikely due to chance alone
and so you'd say okay we would feel good
about our conclusion that this forced
sugar is what is causing that
so anyway well we'll dig deeper into
each of these three types but the whole
point of this video is to just give you
an appreciation that you know we use
statistics a lot but this gives you a
context for how we're using it in
different situations when we were
performing statistical studies this is
to estimate the true parameter for a
population what what is the actual sugar
intake for the population you randomly
sample and then you use that sample data
to create a statistic that estimates the
true parameter observational study you
observe what's going on sugar intake
versus heart risk and you say well I
hate there's a relationship maybe this
is worth doing an experiment on because
only through an experiment could you
attempt to find some type of causality